but Carl's here with me it's asking me
who what in the girl that was the reason
he's here is because of this so that
emergency can authorize the necessary
powers under the 2004 civil
contingencies Act this is now a national
emergency
and cobraman remain existence
consumption
you are the Prime Minister there aren't
you I am the Prime Minister yeah it's a
new series on the Skywalk Cobra yep tell
me about it
well I played Robert Sutherland is the
Prime Minister he's been a prime
minister for maybe but 18 months when
this terrible space where that kind of
phenomenon happens saw the storm which
emanates obviously from the Sun hits the
earth
knocks out all kind of communication
satellite electrics and all of that and
the country's plunged into darkness to
talk about it governor way because we
don't want to give too much away as far
as the storyline is concerned but it is
basically about how a Prime Minister and
his inner cabinet copes when there's a
natural disaster and I was shocked by
how quickly the fabric of society can
break down well I think Ben which has
written some fantastic scripts no
symptom EB can a very realistic what
would happen and then in that instance
you know this things go from bad to
worse basically when this this
phenomenon hits the country and of
course they just don't know how to cope
with it they don't know how taken the
all witness thing various little
fractions makeup they're gonna threaten
someone's leadership his party and he
has to try and cope with that indeed so
while there's a lot of backstabbing
going on around him that is of course
[Music]
yeah Home Secretary played by the
fantastic diva Teague yeah he's my
nemesis in this and I think what again
one of the great things I've ever seen
so accurate looking for any can I say in
a weakness and you can never kill this
he'll that will go for and David takes
consecutively certainly tries to do that
and the Prime Minister has a brilliant
gatekeeper who tries to protect him
other people within cabinet who would
yeah see him well he's chief secretary
on a marshal played by the brilliant
Victoria Hamilton she's his right-hand
woman and she couldn't tries to help him
tell us this
this catastrophe of course one again
it's not just purely a bit there kind of
them the the the solar where weather
problem each one of these characters
have different things happening and the
private likes which come to the before
Anna Marshall has problems and have a
personal life the Prime Minister himself
first has problems which is caused
through his daughter an actual fact
which threatens also threatens that
leave a chef at the party so our my
shoulder that that partner really is
fantastic I mean it's very tricky not to
be able to give too much away because
I've seen all six episodes it's amazing
the Prime Minister and the way that lets
go give too much away but the way that
he dealt with the problems with his
child what did you think as a parent
yourself would you have dealt with it in
that way I think he should worst
nightmare you know I mean I'll go I've
got I've got seventeen year old daughter
and myself again it's hard not to give
our we bit something happens don't want
to I can ask you your character based on
anyone in particular no one in
particular obviously well perhaps that's
the great thing about the research for
playing that the prime minister there's
an awful lot of research material out
there and it was it was gonna be easy
really taking a peck on a few people
here in an important thing shuffle more
than like a pack yeah and we clarified
at the time when I chatted to you and
the other characters the Home Secretary
was definitely not based on Michael Gove
[Laughter]
always far as I know just to be clear in
case but it's gone down so well that
you've already second series is already
being commissioned and it's not even
gone to a and so I understand this is
fantastic
I thought nor thoughts that will happen
before similar harm before from me so
that's great
why did you enjoy working on this
project so much um well I've been
working out in there with a US
television for the past ten years and
that's a different animal entirely
[Laughter]
slightly Canadian so it was lovely to
come back it was lovely to come back to
the UK and lovely again see what can a
commemoration television that was that's
kind of where I came from so I was gonna
look at Amon home again quite literally
enjoy the very very moist of course what
can worth bothering with sky with new
pictures amid it was it was an absolute
delight and January 17th of January all
episodes the way television as these
days you can watch every one of them in
the same way if you wish there you go
I'd remember I was showing off at the
time now explaining to people what Cobra
meant do you remember yes it's a Cabinet
Office briefing room
there you go it's great see and I'm
looking forward to watching it all over
again thanks so much for coming in
Richard